you won't find elon musk living among
his billionaire contemporaries
after promising to sell almost
everything he owns last year
including six mansions in california
tesla's billionaire ceo has taken up
residence in a studio apartment sized
rental in texas
the 400 square foot house is located in
boca chica texas where spacex produces
its rocket ships
the house made by housing startup
boxable sells for about
dollars according to tweets by musk the
foldable
prefabricated homes are set up like a
small studio apartment
one large room partitioned into a living
room area bedroom area kitchen and
bathroom
musk worth more than 162 billion dollars
according to forbes
first announced plans to sell all of his
homes and most of his possessions last
year
in response to criticism of his massive
wealth
musk has nearly made good on his promise
to do so selling
six of his seven properties his last
remaining mansion is a 47-acre property
in hillsboro california
musk listed the 16 000 square foot house
on the market for 37.5 million dollars
having bought it for 23.4 million
dollars in 2017.
musk sold his first mansion in los
angeles for 29 million dollars in june
of 2020
he had purchased it for 17 million
dollars in 2012.
in october he sold a 2700 square foot
ranch style house that used to belong to
willy wonka actor gene
wilder for 7 million dollars he bought
that house for 6.75 million dollars in
and in december musk sold four belair
properties for a combined
61.9 million dollars in total
musk has made an estimated profit of
19.2 million dollars on his six
home sales over the past year in early
december 2020
musk confirmed that he was moving to
texas citing the fact that two of his
biggest projects
tesla's new factory and a spacex
facility are located there
[Music]
boys